OK, we're hearing from people via discord
at David Pakman dotcom slash discord.
I want to go next to let's go to Matt from
Windsor.
Now, Windsor could be any one of a number
of states or even Canada or the UK.
So when you say Windsor, what where are we
talking about?
Windsor, Ontario, Ontario.
Very good, what's going on there?
Well, you kind of caught me off guard, I was
expecting to get called in today, so thank
you for taking my call.
Oh, you were trying to get on, though, right?
I mean, I didn't I didn't totally shock you.
Oh, no, absolutely.
But you were good.
All right.
Very good.
I want to actually ask you, before the election
took place and Joe Biden was elected president,
Donald Trump said at several rallies that
he wanted to implement patriotic education.
Your reaction most of the time was like, well,
whatever.
But I actually have cousins that live in Plymouth,
Michigan, Wayne County.
And I was kind of worried at the moment because
it seems like very much the right wing fascist
propaganda to implement patriotic education
is something you've probably seen Nazi Germany
not to go that far or North Korea.
So how would Donald Trump be able to implement
that if he were to be reelected or could he
even do that during his time as a lame duck
in office?
You know, I really don't think he could, Matt,
because most education in the United States
is based on state boards of education.
So the things Trump could do are sign an executive
order directing governors to tell boards of
education in their states to implement what
Trump considers to be patriotic education.
That'd be one example.
This the Department of Education could make
certain funds available to states only if
they implement it.
But the point is, there is no direct way in
which Donald Trump would be able to do that.
Now, that being said, there's many Republican
governors and state legislatures that would
be glad to put pressure on the boards of education
in their states to start doing again whatever
is being thought of as patriotic education.
But there's really no way for Donald Trump
to directly do it.
No.
Right, well, up until the point where the
election started, I want to tell you that
don't feel so bad about going to United States.
I mean, in other countries we have elections
are going on, and especially here in Canada,
we have a really bad system with a government
that we have in which we almost had an election
a week before your election because of how
scandalous and corrupt our government actually
is with federal government.
What did they do that's corrupt?
So this is going back about a couple of months
ago, and this is not even accurate, but here
here in Canada you can get you can get dropped.
It could be corrupt by bribing.
That is actually a real story.
Go back and look at it.
There's a wheat charity here in Canada called
the charity.
And Chilean government gave about seven hundred
and fifty million dollars around that margin
to benefit schools and other organizations
in Canada.
But what happened was his mother and his brother
gave speeches at these conventions for the
charity.
And majority of the money that the government
spent into the charity would have gone to
his mother and his brother for his speeches.
So wait a second.
Hold on a second.
You're saying you're saying that his mother
and brother got the lion's share of seven
hundred and fifty million for some speeches?
Pretty much.
OK, that seems extremely hard to believe.
So they're like billionaires, you're saying?
Almost.
Well, I might I'm not exactly sure because.
Yeah, I would double check.
I'm going to I'm going to kind of pause this
because I've not heard of this.
And the numbers are sounding.
They're not passing the sniff test, Matt.
But let's look into it and follow up, OK?
OK, my apologies.
Very good.
Matt from Windsor, Canada.
There we go.
I want to be careful with those numbers
for sure.